[Music]
we're here a support a program this is
gonna be so much fun if they're doing
okay telling you buddy like I need to
interview you in case that in the stream
and guess what we're talking now what do
you think it's ridiculous and I was
asking people when you first start
playing for tonight did you ever think
that it would turn into this I mean it
was big
yeah and we heard oh most important game
in the world was one of the game in the
world but like weirdest stadium now and
it's like not even a reason everyone's
stoked to play in the Sun you might want
to try it out it's gonna be big we are
it's next year how does it advance so
fast I have no idea but I cannot wait to
see what happens even when it's a great
of course I'm on both sides of this
streamer and celebrity were like d-level
celebrity but still come on come on I
can do this get a man who can do both
all right
you owe me you've run
I'm great should I hide this logo
sponsor Justine video can you believe it
guys scusi hey so are we gonna do maybe
like a $10,000
you know it's fifty thousand now what so
it's gonna be a fortnight baby oh my
good don't tell anybody okay
you're not gonna post this right he's
gonna keep it for yourself
that's real life change that up editor
so yeah yes I love that don't worry
however you like I'm still editing
hey future me like there's a llama here
what this is a soccer stadium I know and
we're turning people away up so what do
you think of this hearing matchup
because we've got celebrities and
streamers some of the street yeah I
heard about that I was like so how do
they differentiate the celebrity line
because some of these gamer celebrities
are more popular than their I didn't
want to say you're the one that said it
quote me on that
this is fashion world this is a new word
I love it though I love it I mean it's
just like you get out you get to meet
your subscribers meet your fans we're
here gaming I've got to meet myth got to
meet ninja a lot of these watching this
on youtube you don't get the scale I
love it baby just like this is where it
said get on the bus so many jokes okay
Swiss Oh for tonight catch me that's how
we're doing the $50,000 tournament think
about it yes I actually have been
practicing quite a bit
my teammates tyron woodley Walter a UFC
champion and we're very excited to watch
him host the event I was actually
standing outside watching you go through
the dry run to everything that was
persons do not judge anything well
they're great it's gonna be great
it seems a pro honestly there's nobody
better that they could have picked to
host this event like to represent the
community seems crushing it at any and
any setting that she's in that fantastic
I see you guys I got a spinal box
[Music]
that creep a Barbie during this wire
eaters sorry like moving so slowly is
make some sense for tonight pro-am
caster squad we've got golden boy Luke
loudly doctor doctor doctor limo
I met her here already knows I'm all the
nooses uphill Hey feel sad don't they
know that's the virtue of this box so
whatever you think about this whole
event
this is absolutely its wild as many
people here
I've not been more excited
[Music]
yeah we're 30 3,500 there's only 200,000
on Twitch watching right now and did I
seem it started yet the countdown hasn't
even started yet yeah actually I can't
even get over in fact there is
ya know I had a lot of I have a lot of
free time so
a lot of sleep well for me you know I
mean I'm cheap that's a perfect
wowee-wow-wow-wow why we're so confident
I just like yeah I could see in Cyprus
they shame
see so I think you're gonna win II say
that because I am and I don't want you
to jinx it ruin everything concern
because the streamers I'm not afraid of
cars
I have preferably would hope that ninja
gets eliminated my life I don't know
like courage for something like that
that's what I want deserves you'll never
let them live that down you know that's
the best thing it's gonna be is so
unpredictable results which is amazing
so I'm excited I'm so gonna be working
with you guys team team team work let's
go let's go let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
here live and in person and online
joining me today I have some incredible
casters for this event first up let me
introduce you to our invader
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean some noise
[Applause]
[Music]
last but not least we've got the Switzer
[Applause]
so much fun enchiladas are Alderwood I
can't believe it look at this crowd
[Music]
[Applause]
with our Twitter walking it online but
there's so much energy here in the city
of that I can't you just feel it I got
for every single fighters you hear one
massive shotgun blast and the entire
crowd just freaking out lose their mind
because like so and then way moronically
I think IRL that it is you know online
is amazing really it's ready you know I
feel like you work really well together
oh yeah one drive
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're now look we're getting after
partying I actually ran frustrated of
its flush with the best part there's
actually it's a moving bush hey can you
move like do something oh my gosh
[Music]